[Musica]
[Applauso]
in principio era il verbo e il verbo era
con dio e il parco era una singolarità
re vario genesi ad alta densità le
tenebre ricoprivano gli abissi e dio si
muoveva sulla superficie esterna della
matrice iperspaziale se però il
firmamento dal plasma di quark e gluoni
e disse siano fatte le coppie particella
antiparticella e luce fu
creò i pesci del mare e i frutti degli
alberi
la luna e le stelle e le bestie della
terra e allora disse andate sia dei
secondi e mutate e il settimo giorno la
massa riposo dell'universo giunse a
dominare gravitazionalmente la
radiazione fotonica la santifica e la
trentenne se dio con un rapido
spostamento verso il rosso si affrettò
creare luogo dalla polvere di organismi
unicellulari lo chiamo adamo e gli
ingiunse di risiedere nel giardino
dell'eden e di classificare le bestie
per regno film e specie si limitò a
proibire non ama di nutrirsi dall'albero
della meiosi abbiamo fece come gli era
stato chiesto e per ricompensarlo dio
gli insegna la partenogenesi e così
nacque la donna e la chiamo eva e adamo
e eva risiedevano nell'universo per
quantico differenziato
un paradiso privo di del dualismo con la
particella una figura di interferenza si
parla dinanzia era sotto forma di
serpente
e disse mangia dall'albero della
migliosi i tuoi occhi e si apriranno eva
ribatte che non voleva rompere il patto
con dio
ma il serpente le rispose non temere
perché ben legge su una schiuma
stocastica di gravità quantistica e da
un unico morso scaturirà un inesorabile
evento di inflazione ed il rayo quale
dio e di spandere in eterno così eva ma
c'è un frutto dell'albero siete di
essere la figlia nuda di universi
divergenti portò il frutto d'adamo e gli
disse ci sono cose che tu non capisci
ma io sì e adamo si arrabbia le rubò il
frutto e lo vivevo e attiva della
cortina di radiazione cosmica dio
sospirò perché tutti i processi fisici
sono reversibili in teoria ma non nella
pratica uomo e donna furono espulsi dal
giardino spade infuocate furono
infilzate nei cancelli dell'eden per
ricordare che l'universo si sarebbe
iniziato a contrarre e un giorno sarebbe
finito in una consacrazione di entropia
per poi aumentare in densità esplodere
espandersi ancora una volta causando un
ulteriore ridistribuzione ad alta
velocità di serpenti frutti
uomini donne elio 3 17 deuterio ed elio
4 caterina valente 13 modi di concepire
lo spazio tempo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
sono in tournée attraverso molte città
monfalcone venezia udine
lugano trieste catania tutta la puglia
continuo a pensare
penso che mi è stato dato un compito di
preparare a un discorso su technet e
psiche mi viene in mente quello che ha
studiato al liceo tecne la tecnica
psiche l'anima il respiro prova a
pensare come tutto questo possa essere
messo insieme in qualche modo avvicinato
quello che è il mio lavoro è che il
mondo via da qualche parte ho scelto
perché è il teatro e cammino
sono arrivata in una città vicina al
mare cattolica in emilia romagna e anche
nantes e la tournée si attraversano
città e città e molto spesso lo fai di
autunno oppure d'inverno e attraversi
nebbia umidità pioggia qualche compenso
re e sto camminando per le strade di
cattolica e sto per arrivare un teatro e
mi trovo di fronte questa piazza enorme
grandissima quelli sono tre miei
colleghi che cambiavano davanti a me e
questa piazza che si chiama arena della
regina
poco più avanti ci sarà il teatro e per
un attimo penso di trovarmi in siberia
oppure ritrovarmi all'interno di uno
strano film post apocalittico una specie
di hunger games e di essere
improvvisamente sprofondata all'interno
di uno di quei racconti
sto bici che è tanto amò e così mi trovo
a pensare a che cosa possa essere psiche
e terme all'interno di un racconto
distopico e lo penso perché da qualche
parte sento che questa cosa risuona non
soltanto nel mio lavoro ma anche nel mio
modo di intendere lo spazio ed intendere
la produzione artistica e la regia è
inoltre penso al posto dove siamo adesso
penso a questa area ex appiani e penso a
questo quartiere che non esisteva e che
è nato per il volere di un uomo e che
sembra in qualche modo con una città del
futuro
e così guardo la piazza questa piazza
enorme e nella mia testa la forma cambia
e inizia a moltiplicarsi disegno della
piazza inizia a diventare una specie di
reticolato di case palazzi un mondo
futuribile
o forse è un mondo passato che può
diventare futuribile e compiti ciò a
vedere alcune delle città immaginarie
che hanno comprati racconti di alcune
delle autrici che ho amato di più perché
sono i miei modelli
e penso allora racconta dell'ancella che
molti di voi conosceranno perché è
diventata la nonna serie b ora molto
famosa e comincia a pensare a quelli
stati uniti post apocalittici in cui la
fertilità è diventato l'unico
importante è anche una schiavitù
comincio a pensare a racconti come per
esempio quello della cronache è una
scrittrice filandese veramente
interessante che si chiama lettere della
madre
in questo è in questo racconto lei
ricostruisce questa città una città
molto simile al quartiere dove non ci
troviamo adesso è abitata da piccoli
esseri e da una gigante si ma madre che
sta dentro a una di queste stanze
intrappolata
penso a mondi in cui sempre di altri
autrici in cui per diventare manager in
carriera si decide di donare il proprio
corpo alla bioingegneria per diventare
scimmie zanzare oppure continuo a
pensare a mondi in cui appunto nelle
parole di un'altra autrice molto famosa
fantomatiche è una scienziata oltre ad
essere una scrittrice statunitense in
cui improvvisamente l'unica forma di
sopravvivenza dopo l'esplosione delle
bombe è creare una coppia di robot
dinosauri è l'unica salvezza per il
mondo a questo uovo fantasmatico lato
dalla cambiamento di queste due bestie
robotica e continuo a pensare a questo
mondo abbandonato solitario in cui le
uniche cose che sembrano sopravvivere
c'è da qualche parata sono giardini di
inanimati e pensando a tutto questo mi
arriva la ragione per cui ho deciso di
parlare di sì che internet rispetto al
mio lavoro e penso che da qualche parte
per me il teatro
è una grande città distopica penso che
il cubo nero nel quale mi immergo tutte
le sere con quelle luci che sembrano da
qualche parte delle bestie robotiche che
ci guardano e quella necessità di
sopravvive in cui spazio come se fosse
l'ultima sera al mondo da qualche parte
per me è il cuore del v dualismi e cnel
e psiche e quindi mi ritrovo a pensare a
tutto questo fino a che mentre mi sto
preparando per entrare in scena
guardando su facebook ma cellulare vedo
questa foto vedono questa foto che è
stata scattata durante un consiglio
comunale a verona poco lontano da qui
e le donne che vedete sono vestite
appunto come le protagoniste della serie
di cui vi parlavo prima del controllo
galan cella
la serie c o molto famosa anche in
italia
e questa donna e stanno protestando
sopra la parte di un movimento che si
chiama non una di meno e stanno
protestando perché viene stanno stata
non sia stata presa la decisione dai dei
finanziamenti e delle associazioni che
sostengono
come si dice che si oppongono all'aborto
e io penso da qualche parte che questa
condizione passata e io penso che da
qualche parte se veramente una donna non
può decidere del suo corpo probabilmente
davvero ci sono dei segni dinosauri e
robotici che stanno invadendo il nostro
mondo penso che se non è possibile amare
la persona che si vuole amare di
qualsiasi sesso esso sia probabilmente
si sta spalancando o una voragine sotto
i nostri piedi o sta arrivando un grande
tornado che ci porterà via
penso che queste donne oggi mentre noi
parliamo sono armate stanno manifestando
e io penso che per me fosse giusto
indossare anch'io un cappello bianco e
un abito rosso e dire non una di meno e
sostenere la libertà per il corpo
femminile
[Applauso]
[Musica]
meglio tempo è quasi scaduto e io volevo
ringraziarvi e dire che così quello che
ho provato a fare oggi è portarli con me
come nasce un intuizione per esempio
quando cerco di costruire uno spettacolo
a teatro
partendo da un'intuizione arrivando ad
un'immagine poi a temo i danni e poi
infine a quello che per me è il cuore
seguendo quello che è il mio uscite cioè
pigno respiro grazie di aver ispirato
momento